se dan los siguientes números iniciales
y reglas para dos sucesiones numéricas
la primera sucesión sucesión x número
inicial 2 y la regla es suma 3 sucesión
y el número inicial debe ser 2 y la
regla es suma 3 rellena la tabla con los
3 primeros términos de x y después
representa los pares ordenados xy en la
gráfica debajo arrastrando los puntos
anaranjados a los lugares correctos
vamos a ver sucesión x el número inicial
debe ser 2 así que el número inicial es
2 y la regla dice que para obtener el
siguiente número debemos sumar 3
entonces 2 13 5 y 5 3 es 8 esto parece
bastante sencillo ahora vamos a la
asociación y aquí dice que el número
inicial debe ser 2 número inicial es 2 y
la regla para obtener el siguiente
término dice suma 3 así que dos más tres
5 y 53 es 8
ahora tenemos que graficar estos puntos
el primer punto es 22 en el eje x
tenemos 2 y en el eje y tenemos 2 lo
vemos claro x es 2 y 6 2
luego cuando x 5 g5 tenemos x 5 que es
igual a 5 y por último cuando x es 8 18
x es igual a 8 y ya es igual a 8 y vemos
que para cada 3 que incrementamos en el
eje x incrementamos 3 en el eje y aquí
tenemos otra cosa más que contestar los
términos en la sucesión ya son espacio
veces términos en la sucesión x
inmediatamente vemos que los términos en
10 son una vez los términos en x2 es una
vez 25 es una vez 5 y 8 es una vez 8
cuando vemos el siguiente punto vemos
que iniesta se incrementa igual que él
en x así que los términos en la sucesión
ya son una vez los términos en la
sucesión x es correcto